6 24 on your friday morning i want to  explain that lane squeeze up on the  northern 215 beltway at the 95.  let's go  centennial bowling  so the good news is that the beltway's  had all available lanes back open for a  week now between durango and sky point  but i wanted to tell you why that  stretch was down to one lane earlier  this month with a shout out to the  construction crews who finished their  work ahead of schedule  this ndot photo shows a 20 foot wide six  foot tall  piece of a concrete box drainage channel  under the freeway in all they put in 178  feet of those pieces  ever a bad thing to keep reminding you  that this final phase of the centennial  project  won't be finished until 2024.  you can review the online version of  this and all of our centennial bowl  stories at eightnewsnow.com when you  click traffic then driving you crazy  buckle up  drive carefully please put on the phone  if there is something driving you crazy  email me traffic 8  8newsnow.com